jetzt haben wir nämlich hier in der
essenz und wenn wir diese er diese seele
und wenn wir diese seelen ein sold
keeper packen innocence keeper dann
können wir irgendwann little giants wort
mache und das wird so geil dann dafür
brauchen wir diesen lizenzgeber nicht ob
das jedoch richtig geil
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen
back to new pop minecraft hero die
minecraft hexe die youtuber project with
many men youtube
e.on gespielt und ja wir sind weiter auf
der suche noch nach als seite hallo
bruder da was geht entbehren kann man
natürlich auch immer mitnehmen
hallo ob ich da hin wo bis dahin mein
vater der damit sind immer dicker busch
doppelt ab as a dur konzert von mir wir
sind immer noch auf der suche nach da
ist es ist da kommen doch jetzt hermann
der läuft hier vor mir wegner die feige
sau die feige sau die doch das kann
nicht wahr sein der läuft es wieder
richtig gut solche leute auf jeden fall
recht gut
kommissariat 1 0 müssen seine finden auf
dem weg können wir immer noch ein
bisschen nach
das hier war eine tolle höhle ein
bisschen nach mexikaners enzen schauen
kommen wir können jetzt auch einfach mal
rein laufen in der relativ gut
ausgerüstet wir haben stärke der rest
bringt uns nichts dass die skater
natürlich besser oder di figaro einfach
hinten den tiefbahnhof bern hallo jungs
sind stark
welche nicht aber ich will habe
irgendwie anwender von ganz viele kommen
dann sind die halt schon ein bisschen
stark weil mir die schießen alter der
andere war der andere
hallo von da schießt
hey warum steht er nicht stimmt so wir
müssen einfach die caps borner von dem
kaputt machen hat das sind alles nur so
eilers bonner die halt dann treten sie
einmal auf und dann ist vorbei oder wie
die kriegen verlangsamung boost wenn ich
die idee auch keine ahnung ich weiß
nicht was im neuen schweren alles
irgendwie so verzaubert ist jedenfalls
ist der norm verteidigen und passiert
jetzt
ich habe mir ein bisschen irgendwie war
ich weiß nicht ich war noch nie allein
in seiner festung
es läuft relativ gut oder ist gar nicht
so einfach sein ich habe gerade feier
als 1 und da ist noch eine instanz ich
mache jetzt mal ganz kurz meinen
rucksack den ich gar nicht habe richtig
gut auf jeden fall das noch ne sense
auch von den leuten bekommen die ganzen
essenzen 28 chocobo für diesen alle so
mega unnötig chance habe ich zu inter zu
gehen was gemacht
der ging so direkt weg ich ein bisschen
angst hannah locker was geht
wir können jetzt mal die ideen hier guck
mal hier und jetzt jetzt haben nämlich
hier in der essenz und wenn wir diese
diese seele und wenn wir diese seelen
ein sold keeper packen in essens keeper
dann können wir irgendwann little giants
wort mache und das wird so geil dann
dafür braucht er diesen speed nicht ob
das jedoch richtig geil ich nehme das
jetzt hier noch mit dafür lasse ich
einfach mal ich will die bei uns
niederlassen daraus kann sich eine
tollen blog machen
emerald charts zombie hätte wäre ich nie
gebrauchen der ist vielleicht ein
bisschen selten aber nach so nl selten
ist ähnlich aber ich hatte nie
gebrauchen so was ja auch jetzt noch
einer
komm doch nicht hasse ich bleibe jetzt
mal nähe ich guck mal ganz gut sie war
nicht so mein backpack macht beck
greenback big greenback päpste kentucky
wie das geht
keine ahnung das grün und leder einfach
einfach leder
da herrscht anleger gern am 9
nur einer kann jeder wo kriegen wir
schon lange macht ich habe das gesehen
das mich blöd in den augen geguckt da
sprich blätter in den augen geguckt ich
selber was wir brauchen jetzt erstmal in
seinem rucksack kommen egal wir hoffen
dass wir zurück zur stadt ich möchte ja
immer noch diese blöde sei der endlich
wenn diese ganzen die im ganze unruhe
höhle
da könnte sogar seine drin sein
ich glaube die wird sogar noch relativ
groß durch diesen gefühle vorbei freunde
aber gesagt ist eine kleine höhle wo man
muss doch irgendwo sei die seine
es kann nicht sein dass in keiner dieser
verdammten hier und wie sie es hier auch
wenn ich da ganz viele fackeln den
setzte gerade ein kommt er richtig viel
es kann nicht wahr sein das kann ich
bloß scheiße das war meine befürchtung
da kommt ganz viel wasser ein
jetzt hänge ich ja auch noch fest dran
war ich meine fackel hier das müssen wir
sehen könnt ach ist das doof hallo ich
bin luca ich gehe verschwenderisch mit
meinen sachen um so manchmal eben erde
hinstellen ich hasse diese feinarbeit
mit sah raus so blöd wir nehmen schon
nach fünf minuten auf haben nichts
erreicht außer dieser blöde festung
eingegangen da sonntag essenzen bekommen
aber ich möchte wo ich dachte schon die
eisbären brüder als brüder so berührt
mich hätte ich möchte strings ich weiß
dass man ostring wolle man kann man
nicht hier raus irgendwie ähnlich wie
kann ich aus irgendwelchen blumen das
kann doch nicht angehen dass hier
einfach kein links ist die hälfte
erst mal keine existenzen aber okay wir
sind auch relativ nah an der stadt aber
auch einfach keine seite spinnen oder
irgendwas derart dergleichen
ich werde gar nicht läuft hat richtig
flotte komplett falsch oder muss glaube
ich da hin
scheiße wer jetzt nicht mehr die
koordinaten der stadt finde dass wir
doof
wie das vierter sind
doch
muss unsere stadt
scheiße mann bin ich überhaupt schnell
aber nicht so ganz hat 88 er hätten den
lexika lizenz bei seiner andacht das ist
die kirche main kommt eine kirche mein
gott oh gott das bisschen kacke ich will
nach hause
ich bin auch so blöd ist jetzt wieder
nie gegen den punkt oder so ruhig mal
hingehen könnte er ich kann auch nicht
von hier oder was ist das da der karten
er war nicht so im schnee bio-one
eigentlich ich glaub ich bin ich den
falschen weg gelaufen als sie einen
kommentar
blödmann
ihr wart ihr schon welche drin und wenn
ich diese komischen blöcke und spreche
ja da hinten sieht auch viel mehr das
grün aus aber mehr darf bald also das
ding ja da habe ich auf jeden fall auch
schon mal gesehen ich guck mich auch die
ganze zeit um nach afrika lizenzen aber
helfe wo komme ich denn das ist
unglaublich dass mich jetzt einfach
verlaufen habe
die hier auf keinen fall denn schon muss
ich dann da irgendwie so lang laufen
das lauf jetzt
das kann nicht sein ich glaube seit zwei
folgen und ein ich komm hier nie wieder
weg alles was ich gesagt habe ist jetzt
dahin dahin
ich komme nicht nach hause das ist das
einzige was ich will
schön zu mir in meine will
lacht warum ich hier bin keinen plan a
aber die welt ist geil denn ich habe
alles was ich brauche
und nein ich komme nicht mehr nach haus
ich weiß den weg nicht mehr
ich bin raus was ist das sieht das aus
wie eine falle
ich weiß wenn ich zu aber ich habe nie
weh wenn ich wieder beim dings bin weil
der komischen festung gefüllt waren
dann weiß ich wo wir landen müssen
übrigens das ist auch gerade alles so
hell weil ich ja die night vision noch
drauf habe stimmt ich glaube auch meine
berechnungen müsste die stadt da sein
weil wenn wir von da gekommen sind da
müsst ihr dann irgendwo diese komische
burg sein wo ich drin war
dann müsste er da eigentlich die stadt
sein
ich weiß gar nicht wen ich schneller
wenn ich hier die chronisch bringe oder
wenn ich anders laufe ich glaube
eigentlich wenig anders laufen oder ja
da hinten ist die festung wo ich drin
war oder doch das war das tier war die
kirche in die ich reingegangen bin
wir müssten da zu hause sein
das ist so kenne ich laufe einfach die
ganze zeit rum ist einfach das ist eine
expedition folge ich bin nicht nicht
produktiv gefilzt und nichts gemacht
hier
apple direkt vom handy installiert
bekommt starb produktiv wir haben das
bekommen ist dies ja dahin ist die stadt
zahlt sich jetzt auch verdammt und jetzt
bin ich so lange dem doofen falschen weg
gelaufen
manometer lexika lizenzen sind ja auch
keine wahl wenn man vom teufel spricht
bestimmt wann ich die ganze zeit welchem
ich hab die nicht gesehen ich blöd man
aber da haben wir aber egal diese welt
ist geil wenn ich habe alles was ich
brauche
und jetzt noch eine hexe gelassen ich
brauche sie für meine fifa moore ich mir
das alles zusammen sagt nein
dann hatte ich ihm das bein das kann
nicht sein
wie kann man so dressler was entscheiden
könig dieselbe weil sich hier von
shiseido zusammenreimen
die läufer nach hause kommen wir meinen
backpack machen dann wieder zurück zu
der festung und hoffen auf dem weg noch
irgendwie was zu finden
und ja ich gucke jetzt die ganze zeit
rum nach existenzen wir irgendwie rum
liegen können
allerdings habe ich auch nicht meine
augen überall und ich kann alle sehen
war das da oben eine da war keine
schreibt wieder irgendwie land branche
hoch gelegt da waren auch eine visa
stellen nicht gesehen übrigens dieses
diamond zeit
es gibt bei allen möglichen tieren das
könnte theoretisch auch beim huhn machen
und er hat jetzt auch seine seele und
die seele kann ich jetzt einsammeln
damit bekomme ich nie weg metal gilt
und daher kann mitmachen und mega cool
sind
doch man jetzt brauner die kleinen
fucking jetzt hier wieder
zudem ist trocken lassen nein oder was
das anderssein essence vier pfeile wir
genug assistenz auch die etwas stärkeren
lassen bestimmt dann im ice entfallen
die mit einer rüstung oder so die
barbies in der hut die sonne geht auf
falschen weg wo muss ich lang
das haus
wo muss ich lange alter um mein gott
ach das ist schnee ich taktisch ist bio
wenn ich immer total am ende ich glaube
jetzt einfach mal da langt es kann doch
nicht sein ich habe jetzt alles da drum
rum abgegrast oder das lasso statue aber
das nicht unsere oder ich glaube nicht
dass unsere sind im tempel
wir waren auf jeden fall so halb da dran
das hat man bei der charta irgendwie
zurück suchen kann oder irgend sowas
nein geht nicht wo bin ich
bindig alter - 4000 - gibt aussätzigen
100 ist ob ich mich so heftig verlaufen
habe ich muss da hinten hin glaube ich
aber egal wir legen auf jeden fall schön
da mal ein bisschen die welt kennen das
war so geil wenn jetzt in tokio hätten
aber ein thema hat getötet ich finde man
sollte tiere nicht töten im krieg tiere
sind liebe weh liebe geben
ich wollte doch nur helfen wow als er
geil das ambiente
wenn man das jetzt auf vollbild gibt es
bestimmt megane und ja ich gucke schon
ob irgendwelche ecken fänden aber nein
denn keine neben so total die scheiß
aufnahmen gerade die ich hier mache
bestimmt guckt dass keiner an
versprechen die nächsten folgen pinguine
ich finde es immer wieder
ich mache ja das ist die screenshot
folge aber das sieht auch ich geil aus
mit diesem shader es sieht echt einfach
geil aus und muss mich anpassen
ich will jetzt einfach alles was wir
ihnen wie die quere kommt ein brocken
auf leben einfach direct direkten polar
bear vorne hinten bass los wo die karte
schwierig ja das ist ja schon deutlich
besser aus da hinten wir müssen auf
jeden fall ungefähr um die viertausender
koordinator um und nicht so weit weg
aber das hier sieht auf jeden fall schon
mal gut aus goldfäden verstehen war nie
irgendwas geht immer kaputt meine triebe
rüsten geht auch schon langsam kaputt
was ist das hier eigentlich ist einfach
so von obsidian dingsbums er als es
wahrscheinlich im von obsidian denkt fuß
weil leute hat mir geschrieben die
cracks chips die ich mir für mein tolles
schwert brauche das ich unbedingt machen
möchte die bekomme ich nur wenn er so
ein komischer meteorit aus techno wright
irgendwie runter fällt vom himmel
die punkte punkt abwarten ich sehe
unsere stadt ist als unsere stadt
das ist nicht unsere stadt doch das ist
unsere stadt als irgendein anderes
tatsächlich aufgebaut ist aber als ob
unsere stadt so scheiß komisch liegt
hier noch nie glaube ich in säcke ist
auch nicht unsere stadt
dass unsere stadt
was
dass unsere stadt zähle ich bin ich
schon mal wie ich schon mal von dieser
seite hier angekommen bin ich sogar
scheiße habe ich mich im verlauf ich bin
ein ding gelaufen hat mich einfach die
ganz komisch wie handys am start
die handy ist am start so jetzt wem das
backpack machen nämlich nochmal kurz da
hinlaufen und damit nicht mal viel
machen wo es nach hause geht
doch jetzt haben wir gar keine zeit mehr
wieder kg also ich will jetzt einfach
mehr ganzen rhein lebens ist elektriker
sense firedancer sense und daraus können
wir uns jetzt glaube ich wenn wir zum
beispiel poison essence kann man es
einfach machen
dafür wollen essenzen dafür und das ist
das was mir machen möchte ein elektriker
sands die elektrik ist jetzt habe ich
schon
allerdings brauche ich ja diese magic
essenzen dafür brauch ich alle möglichen
sachen und deswegen möchte ich das
alleine machen hier fahren so nee ich
sollte jetzt auch in eine kiste so ein
bisschen und dann mach ich schluss für
heute presserat crystals alter davon
habe ich auch noch so viele exakt carli
finden irgendwo wohl
hallo
jetzt habe ich keine rolle ob man habe
keine rolle da ich habe es keine lust zu
suchen da gucke ich lieber ein bisschen
ach komm ich jetzt erstmal so ein
backpacker habe ich den raub täterinnen
gelassen
ja ich glaub ich sogar mitgenommen so
ein rucksack packte ich dann so ein paar
sachen rein keine ahnung und dann
verzaubert jetzt auch erstmal kurz meine
private schon jetzt ich glaube ich hätte
dass er nicht mehr geschafft mit diesem
ding das da hinten wieder hin laufe so
ich die mail aus ich glaube der helm ist
egal oder ich weiß es nicht ich muss
eigentlich alles aufs alter verzaubern
so soll täter sollte vergessen was
aufzuziehen
sollte taylor acht betriebe längst
vergessen okay gut auch man jetzt macht
er wieder musik ganz laut tschuldigung
falls das ihr ein bisschen stört aber
man muss ja den alten leuten ja mal den
sparten diese kosten das soviel tribalen
leggins sollte mich kam das nicht mehr
leisten egal zwei sachen sind auf jeden
fall schon mal verzaubert so ja egal
jetzt blogger auf jeden fall ein
bisschen vor mich eine art die muss noch
im töten nicht dass ihr dmb sich dann
hier aufregt nicht mal tot so kurz ach
man sonst nie runter fallen waldsterben
spiel so ja okay ist stört
wahrscheinlich sehr heftig ich werde das
nachher einfach versuchen
herauszuschneiden
danke papa wird arbeit so noch einen
schönen apple essen scheiße man
überziehen schon wieder ich möchte
einmal die ganzen sachen hier schaffen
ist das ärgerlich aber ich muss jetzt
beenden
weißt du was ich weiss ist jetzt noch
eben schnell denn die ganzen kisten hier
ein diener hat man sechs minuten länger
gemacht einfach von daher ich möchte
jetzt keine irgendwie regeln ausnutzen
oder irgendwas gegen lena sagen oder in
diedorf kampf im gegenteil
nur ich mache jetzt mal einfach ein
bisschen länger so und zwar so ein paar
sachen mich jetzt einfach noch sortieren
so und jetzt packe ich einfach ganz so
gut und die ganze bäckerei monströse
brauche ich erstmal nicht bis ich das
ganze ding step in the book vorlegen das
ja auch erst mal drin
das exportland sword ich nehme man das
album wixforth jetzt mit sonst würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde jetzt
gefallen hatte würde ich mich meinen
daumen hoch freuen
in der nächsten folge werde ich mich
darum kümmern dass mit den opel werde
ich mich darum kümmern werde ich mich
darum kümmern dass ich so ein paar
sachen hier auf jeden fall noch mache
wie beispielsweise dann die neue rüstung
die fifa moore oder halt ein paar sachen
halt und dann würde ich sagen wenn jetzt
ein nächstes mal wieder einmal gut